I'm Reba McEntire and this is the good
times theater at Knott's Berry Farm well
this has been a big year in country
music you know all through the century
writers and performers have been
planting the seeds of country music this
is country's party of the year the many
looks gorgeous a talented Reba McEntire
she has hosted the Academy of Country
Music Awards 14 times late 1980s and
says different look every year we love
it
the three-time Grammy winner is sold
more than 56 million albums worldwide
earning a record 35 number-one hit
singles thank you very much welcome to
CBS this morning we are so excited to be
the very first to announce Reba McEntire
is returning to host this year's 53rd
annual Academy of Country Music Awards
which airs on CBS CBS next month and
only on CBS this morning
Reba's here at the table yeah you reveal
the nominees for the biggest ACM award
categories Reba yeah morning good
morning what you should know this all
morning long John and I've been doing
affiliates around the country and when
we say Reba's coming what do they say
they say yay Reba we got about 17
different places stations that want to
say hello to you and they've got a lot
of there you got a lot of fans all of
them that's nice to hear and then they
say they love you and because you're
here I wore my special Reba McEntire
last season
Reba has her own boot line because you
look cuter when you're wearing Reba
McEntire boots okay okay we're gonna
start with a category of Vocal Duo of
the year okay and the nominees are
brothers Osbourne dan + Shay Florida
Georgia line loCash Tim McGraw and Faith
Hill now it's their first nomination
ever as a duo how significant is that do
you think I think it's great
I think they're very excited about it
I'm sure here in the nominees right now
yes Tim a question about about duos I'm
doing a duet what's the trick how does
that how do you how do you work it out
how do you find the people well first of
all you got to find if they're available
or not you have your list and then you
start calling and emailing and texting
and say would you please come sing with
me and then it narrows it down to who
can be there and then of course you got
to find the song you got to agree on
the song and then you got to find the
time when both of you can be in the
studio together because it's not fun
doing a duo with somebody when you can't
be there with them when you're said you
have a dream duo partner Bette Midler
available okay next category okay vocal
group of the year right that's right
yeah
Lady Antebellum Lanco Little Big Town
middlin and Old Dominion mmm all right
Hicks they're in that category I know
you know all these people oh my gosh
that's so hard
kind of like picking a favorite child
exactly I love them all okay that's the
luck to all of you right all right up
next male vocalist of the air oh my
boyfriend's here male vocalist of
companies are Jason Aldean Thomas red
Chris Stapleton Keith Urban and Chris
Young Wow Keith Urban 11th nomination
Jason Aldean that's I think his eighth
nomination these guys are that's huh
yeah they are
oh great possible partners for future
duo the next one is the Entertainer of
the Year
and then the nominees are Jason Aldean
Garth Brooks Luke Bryan Chris Stapleton
and Keith Urban mmm is it hard to pick a
boyfriend out of that one no no okay
we've got one more category it's you
have it I got one more right here female
vocalist of the year Kelsi ballerina
Kelsea Ballerini I like her got her
stuff Miranda Lambert love her - Maren
Morris love her Carrie Underwood love
her last one you Reba McEntire thank you
I'm is there anyone you would like to
say yes or no well everybody who voted
for me and my mama so this is your this
is your 16th nomination for female
vocalist of the year no kidding yeah
that was it I would imagine nominations
like this never get old oh no I remember
my very first you do what do you
remember about it 1981 was when we were
out in LA and I got to go to Disneyland
for the first time while we were out in
LA and I was very excited I thought oh
my gosh this is finally
I didn't win yeah it was it was three
years later in 84 when I won I know but
here we are 2018 so in addition to being
a talented musician and artist you were
also the first female colonel for
Kentucky Fried Chicken and also known
now as KFC
how did that happen there you are there
you are in your Colonel gift military
tree
yeah military training they called and
said would you be interested my manager
Clarence balding he said there want you
to be the first female colonel and I
said oh that's so funny and we had a
blast with it I mean you can't take it
serious you look amazing thank you very
much and I've always loved I was in
today do you like he's more of it just
to get in character a lot that's what I
said I had it shouldn't be heard that
part yet I'm working well you can
negotiate now yeah about this album
about faith that you did I mean where
did that are these songs you've had with
you your whole life and I'll fly aways
the song we've all had with us oh yeah
what I was going to do is I wanted to do
a gospel album my little sister Suzie is
the one that does the gospel music and
the family and I didn't want to get over
in her Lane but when I said Suzie
everybody's gonna want me to do it what
do you think she's oh go for it
absolutely give you my blessing and so I
I started looking for songs and I was
going to do five old gospel hymns and
then five new songs well we got a little
carried away in her studio and I had 15
songs and so I just gave them to the
record label and I said y'all pick out
the ones you won't they said we can't do
that and I said why listen we like them
all each one's a winner yeah I said well
what you want to do and they said we'll
go in and record five more and then
we'll do a dual CD of one of the old
songs one of the new songs so you're
hosting again will you be performing
this time or just hosting the award show
I'm begging them
oh they're rubber
most it would seem like you could say
you know this is the part where I'm
gonna perform right here in this slide
right here right here right now well
congrats thank you so much we really
appreciate you coming in
thank all Asians to all the nominees so
many congratulations nominee all good
choices Thanks all good choices you can
watch the 53rd Academy of Country Music
Awards at Sunday April 15th at 8 7
central right here on way Arriba
çb yeah Hans yes sir